en ukraine au menu d'une réunion
d'urgence ce lundi à bruxelles les 27
ministres de l'énergie doivent
s'accorder sur une position commune pour
ne plus être dépendant de la russie sur
le plan énergétique un arrêt progressif
des achats de pétrole à moscou est
envisagée la hongrie a fait elle savoir
qu'elle s'y opposerait précision
explication depuis bruxelles avec alix
le bourdon
la commission européenne a démultiplié
les contacts ce week-end avec les
différents états membres et devrait en
effet mettre sur la table dès cette
semaine une proposition d'un sixième
paquet de sanctions sans doute dès
demain pour une pour une validation
mercredi par les 27 ambassadeurs alors
pas d'embargo prévue sur le gaz russe
qui est envisagé vous l'avez dit c'est
un embargo progressive sur le pétrole
russe jusqu'à maintenant l'allemagne
s'était opposé à cette éventualité mais
le pays a déclaré récemment avoir réduit
sa dépendance en baissant ses
importations de pétrole russe de 35 à 12
% malgré tout cette décision ne sera pas
facile à mettre en oeuvre notamment pour
certains pays européens comme la hongrie
et la slovaquie qui sont des pays
enclavés qui n'ont pas d'accès à un port
ou à un oléoduc européen donc dans ce
sixième paquet de sanctions il devrait y
avoir pour ces deux pays des mesures
spéciales de transition alors on va en
particulièrement observer l'attitude du
premier ministre hongrois viktor orban
qui menacent en effet de mettre son veto
à ce 6e paquet de sanctions mais s'il le
fait on sait on sait aussi qu'il
mettrait en péril son alliance avec
certains autres pays européens les pays
du groupe de visegrad dont la pologne